what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 29th
of november we're back from thanksgiving
it's over and now the full holiday
season is upon us the joint is brought
to you by the flagship on it
listen to me they had their black
friday sale on monday it's been going
great 60 off on everything the hydro
tech the alpha brain black label the new
mood which is [__] tremendous and the
shroom text
anything that they have is up to 60 you
got to go to onyx.com
to look at their prices the protein bars
they're giving away kettlebells they got
club bats whatever they got left
because the sale was massive so i know
you're gonna love it go to honor.com
right now if you see anything that
tickles your fancy
press in
joey
or joint and get 20 percent off
delivered no 10 percent off it on it
delivered to your house not to mention
the sale is going on pressing the code
to see if they throw if you press in my
code when you order a black friday
they'll throw you something extra a
t-shirt a sticker maybe a sample maybe
some protein bars maybe they'll stick
some alpha brains in your [__]
muffler i don't know but honor is
tremendous you're slipping let's start
the year on the right foot with 20 20 20
22 with some alpha brain to get
everything together again
go to honor.com preston joey and get 10
off delivered right to your
[__] crib the joint is also
brought to you by
zip recruiter listen as the holidays as
the holidays approach there's still a
lot of jobs to fill
reindeer [__] shoveler naked office
party santa tree sniffer so if you have
a job opening and help building your
team need to try zip recruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com
joey listen zip recruiter uses powerful
technology
to find the match
that's right candidates with your job
and present them right to you you can
easily review your recommendations and
invite your top five choices to apply
zip recruit is so effective that four
out of five employers who post get a
quality candidate within the first day
can you believe that that's what zip
recruit is about i don't care if you're
the biggest company in the world i don't
care if you're the smallest company in
the world if you're not working with zip
recruiter you're slipping jack no wonder
zip recruiters rated the number one
hiring site in the us let me tell you
something i sent the bio to zip
recruiter they sent me some it's like
they they're tremendous guys right now
whether your business is small or large
whether you're looking for a job or you
got a job to give
zip recruit is the way to go so right
now you can try zip recruiter for free
joey
free it's [__] monday the 29th of
november you need employees why are you
not on ziprecruiter just go to
ziprecord.com
joey that's ziprecruit.com
joey j o e y
z recruiter the smartest
way to hire let's get this party started
jack
this candle i don't know i gotta get a
new candle here this
all the way to the bottom
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
uh
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 29th of november that's
it it's a whole new [__] horizon now
jack i hope you guys had a great
thanksgiving and you had a great weekend
but now it's time for the last [__]
run of the year
which means uh
it's just [__] it that's it guys but
you can't get depressed about it i love
this time of the year you know why
because it's all mondays in my life it's
on mondays
every day you're [__] going off for
the next three weeks till about december
18th
till these [__] gentiles start you
know
you know the [__] christmas jingle
and [__] like that and then uh
that's it you're looking at 22 22
whatever 20 22 22 22 what on my star
trek
[__] uh
but it's great i love all this [__]
because it's coming to an end i could
kill listen man i had a bad 21 21 i mean
emotionally
and mentally everything else was pretty
[__] good i'm strong my family's
healthy you know there was no mishaps i
got a little bit more comfortable in my
[__] surroundings as you could tell
but uh something was off something was
missing all year and not just in my life
alone but in your lives everybody's
[__] life
felt like uh your mother died like
[__] uh you know
you you know i always say that not
having a mother the rest of you like
when if your mother dies and you're like
25 or something after your mom's death
you're gonna go on but it's gonna be
like eating food with no salt on it
you're gonna see that something's
missing so
that's not the case right now i have
that because i don't have a [__]
mother that's my predicament not yours
if you got a mother you're fine you're
not gonna nothing bad is gonna happen
but
yeah my mother's dead is disco so that's
the problem we have here but i like this
time of the year because it really these
next four weeks is all about [__]
journaling
and goals for the fourth first first
quarter of 2022 and what you want
to do that's it what you want to do
that's it this [__] horrible time in
our lives has passed yeah we're all
waiting for the african [__] you know
uh mambada now everybody's waiting for
african mumbada now you know oh there's
a new strain in africa if we're we're
gonna live with this [__] for years guys
don't believe the hype it's probably
this strain probably gives you a little
diarrhea but you're not gonna lose an
eye your hair is not gonna fall off you
know it's they just try to instill fear
in you don't believe the [__] hype
live your life be prepared and that's
all the [__] you could be but i'm
looking forward to this the next couple
weeks because
you know between i'm excited about the
book
i'm excited about maybe doing a one-man
show i'm excited about my health i'm
excited about jiu-jitsu i'm excited
about the [__] guitar hopefully by
february it'll [__] click in and i
could you know it's gonna come up on a
year now and i still suck
i'm picking up some songs some are
better than others but like i said i was
in no rush this is a hobby
i'm not looking to be judas priest or
[__] eric clapton or you know it's
listen you don't want to be anybody
right now everybody's getting grief
right now eric clapton's getting grief
everybody's getting [__] grief for
one thing or the [__] another but i did
have a good weekend this weekend one of
the main things i watched
listen man i'm a little disgruntled with
stand-up comedy not to the point where
you know i'm talking [__] or anything
like that i'm just it's a personal
disgruntle
i have uh
i'm a little upset at myself let's just
say that no no big deal but
this week i got my i watched the show
that
uh brought back my faith
and it was uh kevin hart's show on
netflix have any has anybody seen that
true story
oh la la sassoon it's a good [__]
show
it's uh he's a stand-up comic and you
just see his world with uh my man from
new jack city wesley snipes
he plays his brother in it and it's just
a great show what i like about it the
most is listen i sat here a couple
months ago
and i talked about how we didn't really
have a comedy star anymore
yeah we have people traveling people
touring people doing big toys but we
don't have a guy
that
entertains us like a [__] tv show
or movies every year like you know i
love daddy murphy's movies he [__]
brought it out of me we don't have that
no more what are you gonna do wait for
[__] amy schumer or whatever that's
not [__] comedy that's something
[__] completely different i don't
give a [__] okay party's over it's 20
22. in my world it's 20 22 already i
don't give a [__] you know what i'm
saying but amy schumer didn't cut it for
me i like amy i like the jokes i'm not
saying nothing bad about amy
but i really like comics when they
[__] spread their laughter you know
when they spread their laughter what
happened to comedy i didn't like was
they were pointing they were making
stars on the road in my world that's not
a star a star is something somebody who
the style i liked was you do a little
road work
then you go into a studio and shoot a
movie then you do a little bit more road
work and then you [__] do a tv show
for 13 episodes then you rest for six or
seven episodes for six or seven weeks
wait till the episode come out and now
you toured to support the [__]
episode or the special that you had
that's not the way it was anymore they
don't want they're not pushing comics to
television or they're not pushing them
but the other thing is the television is
not paying
as much as gabriel would make on a
weekend in the road there's no way
gabriel can make that on tv
no way they're just not paying that so
all these comics have said [__]
television
we're just going on the [__] road not
kevin hart watch kevin hart
kevin hart does a little tv
a little film a couple [__] films you
know rock calls him or whatever and then
he goes back on [__] tour and then he
shoots a special he's done for the year
he's a [__] businessman he's selling
pants he's selling shirts he's selling
workouts he's selling health but the one
thing that kevin hart sells that nobody
really catches is motivation i grab a
lot of motivation from kevin hart i know
a lot of you guys look at me
look at what kevin's doing kevin
is a [__] great guy like listen i can
sit here and tell you he's my dog and
[__] but that's not the way it really is
i met kevin maybe three times the only
the only real bond i have with kevin is
grudge match and the movie bombed so
when a movie bombs you don't want to see
those people no more you're like that
that [__] guy was a kiss of death i
didn't look at it that way i had never
met kevin
kevin before
i went down to new orleans with no
expectations and i was on the set one
day with de niro and stallone and kevin
came shook my hand gave me a [__] hug
you know what's happening if you need
something while i'm here the crew he
came down with oh [__] tremendous i
kept bumping into him and different i
only saw kevin like twice i saw him the
day i met him and i told him one other
time
but kevin
has not stopped that was 2012 when i
shot that morning with kevin kevin shot
80 movies since then name another comic
that's shooting 80 movies since then
jim gaffigan i don't [__] think so
this guy i don't think so this guy i
don't think so
kevin has his own [__] career
chappelle's doing what he wants to do
terrorizing [__] and this other
[__] guy is [__] out there i'm
just cracking a joke i'm not mad at him
you know
it's kind of fun to see him get [__]
tortured every day they threw him out of
his grammar school last week
you know it's all over
[Music]
yeah yeah because he's if he's in town
he's working he's the hardest [__]
work and yesterday he was some college
well today's on
new orleans [__] giving out picks for
somebody you know this is and i like
what he does he spreads it around all
the other guys want to do podcasts and i
get that not kevin and i got to tell you
something you know who else liked that
life too
me i could just never reach it
i can never reach it my agents or
managers whoever didn't have the respect
for me to listen to me
and to push me in movies i i miss great
movies i miss the [__]
the [__] one with de niro and joe
pesci i missed the [__] one with the
with nick vallalong and his father i
missed all those movies and i gotta tell
you something
till this day
i have a little bit of grudge against my
agency for that
because they weren't looking at that as
things as i was looking at us to be
important kevin's to a point he could
tell [__] either do this or you
you go packing
i didn't have that i didn't have that
type of push and i'm not angry at kevin
i'm
celebrating kevin i'm celebrating
kevin's show i watched uh
i'm probably up to episode six
and i really [__] love it i think
he's doing a great job i think whoever
wrote it for him
was [__] fantastic
it's one curveball after another
curveball after another curveball and i
enjoy that type of [__] so if you like
kevin hart if you're kevin hart fan i'm
giving you a [__] uh green light go
watch that thing on netflix i think it's
[__] tremendous i really do that's
just the way i feel
i applaud kevin on a daily basis for the
lifestyle that he lives he's healthy you
know listen you never hear a negative
thing from kevin what do you hear about
kevin oh you cheated somebody caught him
cheating or whatever listen let me tell
you something
what this whole [__] country's
forgotten
is that half of these people got into
comedy for different reasons some people
got into comedy to do drugs
some people get yeah i got into comedy
to do drugs and travel and you know get
syphilis and conorea and you know
[__] wake up in the morning like tom
behrens your major league that's why i
got into comments i didn't get into
comedy to be a [__] saint or to
change the world or the [__] i'm
gonna show them i got into comedy
because i was a bum i had nothing else
going on you understand me so it's
either comedy or being obama i'll give
comedy a shot and here we got you know
what i'm saying i i over [__] came
the odds and here we are but i support
kevin that's it
that's all i want you to do
the other thing that happened this week
and what didn't happen this weekend it
happened
sunday morning that i was just blown
away by
because it didn't blow me away because
this is life
this is what life is all about right now
every time a person takes two steps up
somebody's got to come out of [__]
the world of yahoo or whatever and shut
them down
think about it from now on i want you to
notice these things i want you to notice
people trying to do positive things or
they come up with something positive
and right away two weeks later there's
something about them well you did this
eight years ago
why are you trying to take away from the
guys [__] glory day you got a beef
with something he did
pull him aside and go hey man
congratulations on your movie
but i felt you did this or whatever but
it doesn't even matter
you guys know i was very excited for
that release on hbo about king richard i
was really excited for that i wanted to
see how
a dad took two daughters and made him
[__] tennis stars that's the same
thing i share right now i have that
aspiration mike has that aspiration he
has kids
whenever i can learn
or observe how to be a better father
something i'm not doing and that close
to anything in life you know what i'm
saying when
when my comedy when i was coming up in
comedy if i i went and i watched and i
studied and you know i told you guys
that
in 2008 i was coming off the blow for a
year a lot of people don't know this so
i said you know what i'm going to slow
down with the comedy a little bit and
every thursday i decided to drive out to
irvine to watch different headliners i
watched neil geraldo i watched patrice
o'neal i watched so many [__] guys
and that taught me how to headline for
ye i did comedy for
16 years
i had an hour's worth of material
but i wasn't a headliner
learning to be a headliner is a complete
different [__] situation but anyway
who gives a [__] about that
the thing i'm going to talk to you about
is something that would happen to me
and it does happen to me
every 90 days
okay
every time i have a little bit of
[__] uh
success in my life whether it's the nfts
when i release the weed one of the many
saints in newark when grudge match came
out
after i shot a special
there's always one person on the
internet or maybe two of them that'll
throw a jab at me about my daughter
they'll say to me hey man how does your
daughter fly into all this and it's a
it's a kind of a hurtful jab
but it's not a hurtful jab i've learned
to understand why people do that they
didn't
get the real story maybe they didn't
agree with what i did
right now i'm writing a book i'm in the
process of writing a book i woke up for
months going [__] i'm not doing anything
with my life
and then i realized i'm on like chapter
20 of this book eric and i are doing a
real job we're committed to it i sit
around with a pet and pencil every night
a pet paper and pen and outline the
upcoming chapters and we've worked
really hard on this and i'm really doing
a good job for you guys in fact when we
hit the end of the book we're going to
go right back to the beginning for about
five or six chapters because that's when
i had done the surgery and my mind was
shot and i want to cover a lot of things
that i left out of those chapters i'm
trying to put something really nice
for people to read you know i went and
searched your pictures i'm putting a lot
of effort into this [__] book right
now
i believe in this book i don't think
it's going to change my life or anything
i don't want to make a million dollars
what i want to do is to have you guys
have the whole story right there and
[__] funny with the pictures and i'm
done i've done my [__] cycle i did my
stand up for 30 years now i'm putting
out a book about those 30 [__] years
and you know ralphie may whitney houston
we're going on we're going with
everything in there this book is going
to let people know who the [__] i am
front and [__] center
and it also
explains
there's like three chapters dedicated to
it
of what happened with my life
and my daughter and why i made those
decisions and whatnot anyway let's get
to the front of the story so
i wake up sunday morning i do what i
always do i make my coffee i go outside
i do my grateful [__]
five things i'm grateful for i look at
the sun i look at the sky i thank god
for giving me another day
and i come down here
and i [__] uh
i'm looking online i'm doing my little
homework i'm answering patreon back i'm
putting little this is how i get i got
like four notebooks open right so i got
like
[__] patreon over here i got like uh
what i have to do schedules i mean it's
always something i got the scripts for
the [__] podcast it's always [__]
something but i usually go through the
important things and i do my reading i
go to yahoo and i see what's going on in
the world i see what pics they're making
for the day you know they've got good
things on yahoo
and i see something that uh
you know
king richard the movies get negative
heat because the family
before
these girls he raised he left them he
walked out on five kids or something
so they want to know why they're upset
because they didn't put them in the
movie or give the [__] backstory to
him
and i'm sitting there going what the
[__]
it's a great movie this movie is about
his relationship
with his girls of present
and two girls which
became [__] icons the greatest
athletes in the [__] world if you
watch a football game watch any sporting
event you're going to see the serena
williams sisters five or six times doing
[__] commercials and it's tremendous
i i look at it and i go and this is way
before black lives matter like they've
always had [__] 10 million dollars a
year and just commercial so for all you
you know all hollywood's racist take a
look at those [__] two see how racist
they are against them that's just the
way life is that two women are
tremendous at what they do they've had a
little negativity over the years but
they're tremendous [__] athletes and
i just found out that the other three
girls he had so he adopted those two
girls like he had those are his two
girls but when he married us she had
three girls before and he adopted them
one of those girls is a lawyer
one of those girls is a [__] doctor
and i forget what the other one does so
in my world that's five i know you did a
good job whether the kids went out of
yours
were yours or not
you did a [__] great job so today i
wake up sunday i wake up to this [__]
about well
the girls from his previous [__]
marriage
why didn't he put that in the [__]
thing or whatever you know what because
that's not what the [__] story was
about
and when i see [__] like that i think
about my life and i think about people
how people have reacted to me i had a
guy on patreon a couple months ago
nice guy i had a great relationship with
him on patreon answering his messages he
must have gone out and got [__]
hammered
and he spilled his guts on you know
where you should go and be a [__]
father i still can't put together how
you walked away from your [__] dawn
and i'm looking at this going this isn't
even a guy that's
a nice person
he's just a guy that's trying to be
[__] hurtful that's what you got out
there you know when people are hurt they
hurt when i was hurt when my mother got
taken from me
my business was to hurt other people i
didn't have any [__] coup about it
you don't
so i i you know i took it easy on the
guy i just never answered him back again
i could have called him a [__]
your father sucks
i just said you know what these are
these people but then i looked at his
previous messages
he was cool for four months before that
but this must have been on his mind for
years and it was if i read you the
attack guys you'll go holy [__]
it didn't matter to me because you know
what
he wasn't there
when you hear a negative story about
somebody that's putting out something
positive like what happened with that
film
it's a positive [__] film about the
story of these two girls guess what it's
a film there's gonna be a little
[__] in it
have you not figured that out yet
if you watch goodfellas there's [__]
and if you if you read the script the
wise guy and then watch goodfellas
there's [__] in it what happened to
paulie's [__] son in the book
he didn't make the script in the [__]
movie it didn't fit right maybe he
didn't want to be in the book you know
have you ever there's a thousand books
that i've read when you watched to read
the donny brasco book and then watch the
movie before donny brasco arrested all
those guys in new york he arrested the
ballisterry crew out of [__]
milwaukee and chicago the ballisteries
were in charge of vending machines and
all that [__] he did bro there's three
chapters dedicated to the ballisteries
in the [__] book when you watch
donnie brasco they know there's no
mention of milwaukee jeffrey dahmer what
a [__] ballisteries whatever the [__]
that name is sorry you know i'm not good
with names and [__] you know you don't
[__] know so i always want you to
remember one thing when you have a book
and then you turn it into a movie except
don't uh
hannibal lecter the first one silence of
the lambs the book is the [__] movie
word for word they won't they don't miss
a spot they go directly how the [__]
book was written but all these other
movies they're all [__]
there's a little bit of [__] in all
of them especially if it's a movie about
a biopic
there's gonna be a little they're gonna
have to jump over something or not
mention something
but at the same time
[Music]
look up
i
knew i for the last time for the last
time in 2021 i'm going to talk about
this i don't want to talk about this
anymore
i don't care anymore
it was a long time ago
god threw me a gift
to let me know i was fine the gift is my
new daughter my old daughter doesn't
want to talk to me my ex-wife don't want
to talk to me what am i going to do
do you want me to go cry do you want me
to jump off a [__] bridge
no
and this was the same case in 1995.
i knew from 1992
that i was never going to have that
daughter that share that door it was
going to be
like that other guy they were going to
treat me like the other guy they weren't
going to cherish me i never got a
christmas card from her a father's day
gift i never got nothing from her after
her and i broke up so she was never
gonna put that effort into a
relationship i was always gonna be
like the third spoke
i had something to say guys
i had a life there was things i wanted i
wanted to live my life my life had been
[__] up to that [__] point and i just
wanted to move on
go out there i knew i could do something
with my life with comedy and i did and i
was gonna [__] in the middle come
back and explain to her that life
changes that never occurred to me that
was my long-term plan
but it never worked out for him but it
never meant that i didn't love her it
didn't mean that i didn't want to be
with her i didn't want to be held down i
didn't want to be held down
under somebody else's [__] thumb
i was in prison when you go to prison
you learn one thing about prison prison
is not about punishment prison is not
about growth they don't give a [__] what
you're doing there it's to let you know
that you're going to be held down and
that you're a piece of [__]
like i said to you you don't know
anything about life until a man kicks
your bed and tells you to wake up [__]
nut and just puts the light on that'll
make you that's in the realm of getting
raped in your ass as a man it's the same
feeling when a man comes into your room
kicks your [__] bed and turns the
light on and says let's go dirt bag wake
up that's what you're waking up to and
that's what you wake up tonight when
somebody kicks your bed every day and
calls you a dirt bag by the time you hit
the shower if you take a shower because
you're a [__] dirt bag by the time
you hit the shower how do you feel
is there anything good that grows from
that so that's what prison is guys
that's exactly what prison is there's no
rehabilitation there's no you lift
weights and you figure it the [__] out
on your own but the number one thing to
figure
is why do i want to be in general that's
why there's people who are
institutionalized they can't live on the
outside world without being
institutionalized when you see people
have been locked up for a long time and
they come out how long do they really
last they don't want to be in [__]
society
you have that that all stems from that
[__] cell
so when you wake up in the morning and
you already have negative [__] going
into your brain the same reason i don't
watch the news in the morning you know
when you turn the news on you're making
coffee and you're eating captain crunch
and often they tell you a kid 14 got
shot last night you don't want to start
your [__] day with that going into
your mind even if you're not paying
attention to it that thing is going into
your ear and it's going into your
[__] psyche some way or another this
is why in the morning you powder your
balls you salute the flag do not turn
the tv on do not turn the radio on put
on the [__] stereo put on your
favorite album the mob rules i don't
know barbra streisand's greatest hits i
don't give a [__] put it the [__] on
yeah i like barbra streisand
i saw the other day she was fine i
didn't see her i was reading an article
about [__] uh
the guy who died uh sondheim and she
wrote a thing for him anyway a lot of
gay people are depressed today my heart
goes out to the lgbt community madonna
and everybody else my man sondheim his
[__] gun
and he was a bad [__] so anyway
back that i was saying
you know i'm putting out this book now
it's i have to hand it in by march we're
going to try to handle a little earlier
you got to get pictures in there you got
to get legal to go through the thing who
knows when we're releasing but i'm sure
people are going to come at me and say
well you know you didn't put enough in
there but i gave you everything in that
book about my daughter how i felt
why i did the things i did
and in the end i told you that i still
[__] love her i still love her and i
still wish for a life with her
in my 60s and 70s but it's doubtful i
don't see it happening and guess what
i've accepted it
what do you want me to do you can't make
people love you you can't make people
talk to you you can't you can't do it
you can't do it and guess what i
the other side of this coin was you guys
didn't know me in 95
and you didn't know what i had become
the same way i got overtaken by comedy
was the same way i got overtaken by
my ex-wife with the divorce i put
everything
i made a plan
i stuck to it
and my plan
was never gonna be good enough for her
she ended up kicking me in the [__]
stomach anyway
so
you moved the [__] on i could have dwelt
in that for years and i never would have
got here
i would ended up a [__] junkie in
dead i would have died 20 [__] years
ago if i would have let that get to me
that was eating me up inside guys i'm a
big man to say that he was eating me up
inside it was fueling my [__]
addiction
and it was
not making me think clearly
and once i sat down i
journaled out the matter
and i put it in [__] god's hands my
life worked
i know there's still some people who
have a problem with me
about not speaking to my daughter guess
what if you got a problem with it
don't it's none of your [__] business
and the only problem you should worry
about are the problems in your [__]
life it doesn't bother me anymore
i enjoy my new life with my daughter and
you know what i follow her i understand
what she's doing she's up in aspen she's
selling real estate she's enjoying her
life
why would i want to step into that and
[__] her head up
more than it's already [__] up at this
point she's going to be 32 years old in
february
and can you imagine
her life right now
she's dirty too she's got to have some
friends that watch joe rogan they have
to have some friends that watch burke
crystal and you know my name has to come
up in her world or maybe not but she's
got to sit there and go
i don't watch that
well i don't like joe rogan or whatever
other things are connected to me in my
life i mean you know how many
connections do i have out there
somebody in her [__] world
has to be saying don't you listen to
this and she's got to move on she's
living like i was as a kid
that [__] [__] i lived in as a kid
where
my parents were involved in all this
[__] illegal [__] and
i couldn't say that to nobody
it was just [__] deep secret in my
[__] soul that kids would talk about
coke like they thought they knew what i
was talking about i was ready to go you
don't know nothing shut the [__] up but
i couldn't because they would go how did
you know oh my mother sells coke i
couldn't [__] say that oh my mother's
a bookie i couldn't say you know we were
kids i couldn't go well the knicks are
going to win tonight honey you know
because my mother took action on the
[__] nick game and all the money's
going on the [__] knicks against the
net you've never seen a bookie with a
[__] part-time job have you so you
know you learn all these [__] things
so
you can't really
so i i always think about her
and what's going on in her world you
don't really think if you know any of my
stories and anything that i'm capable of
you don't really think i want to drive
up on her
and get to the bottom of this
but i can't because i got to think of
the rest i got to think of what she's
going through
and what you know her friends or
whatever can she even say that i'm her
father
she has to hide that
i'm very sure in fact i'm 99 sure
that they've never told her brothers and
sisters
that i'm her father what do you want to
make a bet
i will guarantee that her brothers and
sisters don't even know i exist
they never told her that
so that girl lives with a secret have
you ever looked at a secret
[__] sucks doesn't it
sucks
sucks somebody you suck the [__] in the
8th grade now you're 28 years old
you're like
what the [__] is up with my life
i mean yeah these are things you got to
[__] think of you know i [__] hate
it but
it's the truth i enjoyed king richard
when i watched a movie i i
never thought about anything else i just
focused on the story of these beautiful
[__] girls
and what they ended up doing with their
life i didn't care about anything
[__] else why would i
but there's always some people who can't
let it [__] go
who can't let it go
that your success is important i listen
guys
i dealt with it
for close to
from the very time i opened my mouth
that i was a felon and started telling
my story from beauty and the beast
i've been getting [__] hate mail and
guess what i don't even give a [__]
because they never understood that i
opened up to say it you know how much
balls it takes to get in front of a
[__] camera
and tell people that you kidnap somebody
when you're trying to build a career
it's not it's not really a career
builder do you know what i'm saying
do you know how hard it is to try to
build a career and get into movies and
you know and i'm sitting here twice a
week telling you guys about you know
[__] robbing a pool hall or robbing a
[__] uh gas station or you know going
up to idaho and fingering an american
indian girl and [__] uh having
[__] uh what do you call that [__] on
your finger
[__] uh
i swear to god she had a yeast infection
so when i fingered it was like yogurt on
my fingers i could smell it on my hand
the rest of the night do you guys need
the stories about me [__] and
cemetery i've told you some
stories that most people wouldn't open
up to you about
uh
and i did it with my heart with laughter
i don't give a [__] why because it
happened
and i want you guys to know it so in 10
years from now when it comes out joey
diaz once took a [__] in the cemetery
you're just reporting that now he told
me that on the podcast in 2000 [__]
10 you dumb [__]
but that's what it's all about i didn't
want to hold back nothing from you
[__] because i didn't want that
to happen look what happened last year
with all these people now what came out
from that
all these women stuck up for me i had
not that i had treated that's what you
do when you're a male comic
yeah you're going to bump into chicks
that want to sniff your nuts and then
you have to control yourself but when
you're a young comic you don't have any
[__] control this is why you got into
the comedy game
to [__]
[__] suck do drugs and not have any
responsibilities and now 30 years later
they want you to be for everybody be jim
gaffigan not have a past and talk about
bacon and [__] go [__] your mother i
don't want [__] a straight up comic i
want a comic that's got some [__]
restroom you understand me i want a
comic that has a little life to him i
like listening to chappelle i like
listening to [__] rogue and i like
listening i don't want to hear about
[__] bacon all day and you white
people clapping for that [__] i don't
give a [__]
it's over dog it's 20 22. it's time for
therapy real quick
here now for a word
from my [__] sponsor
for the last couple months i struggled
and uh i made a decision not to struggle
so
without further ado the joint
is brought to you by
better help online therapy listen better
help want you to know
the truth about some of the stigmas
around mental health i had the same
stigmas and they're gone therapy has
helped me
so [__] much i didn't even know i
tell you what man and this is the beauty
of it i'm dealing with anxiety
but through therapy i found out that
it's the same thing why are we taking a
pill
there's work to be done so when you go
on better help they actually give you
worksheets
and they talk to you about cognitive
behavior and all this [__] how to push
bad thoughts and all that stuff out of
out of your mind now you guys have been
watching me for years you've never heard
me talk about these things i took this
seriously
the pandemic the whole thing has
destroyed people's lives a lot of people
don't know where they're [__]
standing where they're thinking and i
was one of those people i'm not ashamed
to [__] say it i contacted betterhelp
and my life is completely [__]
different many people think therapies
for so-called crazy people that's a lie
therapy doesn't mean something's wrong
with you it means that you're
recognizing that we're all humans and
that we all have emotions and need to
learn
to control them and avoid them therapy
is a tool to utilize before things get
worse i got a sign sent to me march 2nd
i'll tell you some other time i was
going to uh agent's house to watch the
chinese girl from the ufc
fight rose or the other girl the the
russian girl with the brown hair but
that always does the toenails and stuff
and i was acting erratic i was getting
in and out of a car i didn't recognize
that
that was what my anxiety really was i
never tagged it and this is why i am
here today so i'm very happy i found
better help don't wait until it's
[__] unbearable better help is
customized online therapy they offer
video phone and live chat sessions you
don't have to see anybody on camera if
you don't want it and i'll tell you what
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can start communicating
with your therapist in less than 48
hours i had a third i'd still deal with
her name is dana
she uh
had nice gloves in the beginning she
held me together and here i am today
starting to kick some [__] ass so
listen don't hold yourself back
20 22 is right around the corner give it
a try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online therapy and
just for the joint listeners what we're
going to do is we're going to give you
10 off your first month joey that's not
much but it's gonna help you first off
better help's not overly expensive so
you're already getting the break and i'm
gonna uncle joey's coming at you with
ten percent you got no excuses so do me
a favor go to betterhelp.com
that's betterhelp.com
d-s-d-i-a-z
diaz take control of your life and get
the [__] help you deserve [__]
trust me i did it
and i feel tip top magoo it took a while
it took a while and it takes work on
your end guys
you're not gonna [__] they're not
gonna you're not gonna do therapy
they're gonna send you medication you're
gonna sit in front of the [__] tv
and watch [__] all day no you gotta work
a little bit you gotta go for a walk you
gotta get some vitamin d you gotta
[__] take your vitamins you gotta do
a thousand [__] a thousand things
before you even have to do anything when
you're taking care of yourself it's your
health [__] suckers better help
slash diaz now where the [__] were we
mike i don't even [__] know this
whole therapeutic qualm got me out of
[__] pickle
so yeah it's just i don't know
you know i don't know what people are
supposed to i don't know what how people
want you to act
like do you
do you want me to walk around wounded
you know i'm sure a lot of you people
want this got divorce is a very hard
[__] transition okay
very hard transition when you get
divorced
talk to people who have been divorced
it's a [__] nightmare don't get
divorced it's too much paperwork the
kids the attorneys everybody [__]
lies to you
don't get [__] divorced but if
you divorce somebody how they gonna feel
about you
if you contact somebody's ex what are
they gonna say about
he's a great guy
he's she's a great woman nobody nobody
very seldom do people break up and go
you know what we just we just didn't get
along
we're gonna go our own ways now it just
doesn't work that way there's always
some type of [__] animosity you know
so
whatever i don't even know how we got to
the [__] animosity and the divorces
who gives a [__] it's monday november
the 29th guys
and we got what 29 one more day november
has 30
31 holy [__] guys this year's got like
33 years left 33 days left 33 years
jesus christ
i'm thinking i'm looking at that
physical graffiti album too much 10
10 years gone is the [__] name of
that song
but no i just uh
didn't understand that this morning and
i was talking about me and my wife were
talking about it sunday morning
at breakfast how people you know are
going after him now the daughter
the one daughter was going after him
from the previous marriage he's living
with a he's got a son
dog
they're african [__] americans
you know this guy
i mean you don't expect to fall like
this you know before i
john bernthal is in the movie so i
remember john bernthal
having a conversation
about his father and even bernthal did
some deep you know john as an actor
really good actor he he digs deep into
everything and he was like the guy had
some [__] issues
but all that all that that movie should
make you
want to do is honor your [__]
daughters
i watched the movie and i was like okay
i'm on the right [__] path here i'm
not beating my door i would never raise
my hand to my daughter we discussed that
10 years ago and this is not happening
when the nun hit me i don't believe in
hitting [__] kids
you know what when i got hit it didn't
[__] change who i was it didn't
when you get hit when you're older you
learn you know when somebody hits you
for not paying you drugs or when you
don't pay a bookie or something like
that it's one different thing but no my
mother and parents had me isn't wood
if i looked deep at it it was when
people spoke to me it was when people
pulled me aside sat me down looked in my
eyes and talked to me and said just look
at it for yourself
you're doing something wrong and at
first i'd be a little apprehensive but
as you go along you're like yeah it was
me and then it all goes away i'm not
here to blame you know
one of my biggest [__]
weaknesses for years
was not
copying to the truth not copying to your
mistakes not
you know recognizing your mistakes and
going [__] i [__] up that was one of
my biggest that's why they drew me in
jail i didn't get thrown in jail because
listen
between me and you all three of us
should have been in yeah me vela and
[__] tidwell you know i didn't like
that they made
vela a [__] victim but that was then
this is now we overcame that
i'm happy that i told you guys about my
kidnapping i'm happy i told you all
these things so when the book comes out
and you read it i even got whitney
houston in there for people who don't
want to hear that i had to i'm opening
up my heart to you guys i'm i'm going to
show you my struggle from my youth
i'm going to show you my struggle in
prison i'm going to show you my struggle
as a comic and i'm really having a good
time with the comic struggle because
it's not as you know the book turned
after prison after i leave my daughter
and stuff like that after i moved from
boulder
the book takes an edge that you look at
and go what the [__]
we were going through all this hell and
fireworks and prisons and people getting
smacked and people getting yelled at and
people getting buried and now we're at
this calm [__] of the storm
which was my comedy career it was very i
struggled
but it's not as the struggle that i had
in my earlier [__] uh
in my earlier in my youth so you're
gonna struggle for [__] that but
there's always going to be people who
are going to try to [__] derail you
like they tried to derail this [__]
will smith movie who gives a [__]
those people go the [__] away when they
can't get that way see because everybody
always wants something
i see you people got to remember that's
why whenever you see an artist
movie star athlete
he accomplishes something really good
ten days later there's something
negative in there and we all believe
that [__] don't believe it you're not
there and right away you attack whoever
the [__] they're talking about that's
not the way it is somebody was not happy
a couple months ago we saw something
that was very shocking i didn't get mad
at them i didn't say nothing but it made
you think it was when rogan got the deal
nobody really said none of a couple
people complained you know people tried
to knock them down now that they they
just gave up now they're not even
quoting them on everything now the horse
worm and all that [__] but
i don't even know what i was going to
tell you about rogue and who the [__]
gives the [__]
[Music]
that's what happens when you switch
people you know as soon as he got the
hang of do you remember marin went off a
couple months ago
he was dead he was doing tom segura's
thing and he actually said [__] joe
rogan
he does those noise i'm not mad at
marrying for doing it i expected
somebody
to [__] be mad about rogan getting
the deal
i expect i wasn't mad i was happy for
him i never said a negative [__]
thing about i was just cracking jokes
the whole time i've had 20 conversations
with joe
about you know how positive it was and
what a great time we have but even that
and i'm not mad at marin i'm not
badmouthing marin i like mark mark's put
me on his shows me and mark have great
conversations i think mark is a great
musician i'm just using mark as an
example
that you know mark went on thomas the
girl one day and just
you know
you know he let his emotions go
i wouldn't have
done something like that i'm sure i've
done things like that in the past on the
podcast
upset of somebody who you know but it's
not
i was never upset with joe i'm not
listen guys
to become
to grow
as a human being as an artist
you have to be happy for your peers
sincerely from your heart i'm not
talking about
i'm so happy for mikey's and the foo
fighters now and i'll turn around
because i'm walking [__] mike can't play
the [__] guitar
no i'm talking about and i can look you
guys in the face all these
and tell you that when my brother josh
wolf in 1999 got that deal again i'll
tell you for 10 minutes
i thought negative things and i said
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
you're in the karma business uncle joey
you have to be happy
for them with no [__] snags
you have to check your stomach you know
how you always in your stomach it'll say
like [__] that [__] no no no
it's got to be pure
and when you attain that happiness for
other people you will start to [__]
grow
try it
instead of [__] looking for people
short end
just say you know what i'm happy for
that [__] i have disagreements
with him but i know the work he put in
because i put the same work in and now i
know the work i have to put in to
accomplish the same goals as him and
trust me
dog we do it with music all the time
i'm a real critical music [__] fan
but i always like
okay i'll tell you some [__] i was
thinking about the other day by myself
in the car that [__] bang greta van
horn came on
whatever the [__] greta van fleet i like
the songs okay the songs are great but
you [__] that compare them to
the led zeppelin after four songs you
better get your [__] [__] together
it's like in the ufc when a guy takes
like a three fight skit and he wins
decisively and all of a sudden you're
like he's back let's give him two more
fights
i see how back he really is let's not
get excited let's sit tight and see how
he reacts to this
we don't you know we just go [__]
nuts on this [__] so i i don't believe
it's the truth they just seem like
they're trying to be like that
i like them i'm not saying nothing
negative about them i just want you to
understand that i'm just saying
led led zeppelin
out nine [__] albums
okay
the accomplishment wasn't the nine
albums you know what the accomplishment
was with the band they stayed together
that's the accomplishment of the band
how long can you stay with what if you
come to your girlfriend i i think i want
the next album to be acoustic acoustic
and they start going off we hate
acoustic you know
yeah
that's what's gonna you know
so i don't know you gotta [__]
believe in your moves
you gotta eliminate all the [__] they're
gonna say about you and just believe and
listen guys i had to go through this if
you don't think
every time i got an accomplishment and i
saw people on twitter i'm like
who the [__] is gonna raise their hand
this week
i'm surprised none of the guys i did
time with
have raised their [__] hands not one
of them
one guy called in looked me up uh
alexander
alex alex breyer whatever he was on the
podcast when we first uh
i forget what his name was he was my
roommate in the halfway house max
mexican kid
alex or whatever his name was but that's
the only guy i reached out to a guy
andrew purdy as soon as that [__]
longest yard came out i thought it'd be
20 convicts i did time with that
[__] he almost blew up the
kitchen one time with his [__] bagels
and [__] that dude used to hold steroids
for the mother you know i i didn't know
who was gonna come out and raise the
hand but you know what nobody [__]
did and when those other people two
years ago came out and oh he got his
dick sucked in the belly room who else
came out to raise their hand one person
that stiffs
that poor fat bastard that's dead's
[__] creepy wife
i showed him my [__] why would i show
you my [__] nobody's even hit on you
since the [__] guy died but anyway
that's a complete sniffing story why the
[__] open up that can of worms it's
[__] monday jack and we're
fired the [__] up november 29th we
finally got here you know what the
year's been [__] lumpy but better
days are [__] coming i know you
people like joey they closed israel
we're going to claw listen
wake up take your vitamins keep slinging
dick check our [__] ex our [__]
party
is just starting i've been down for a
[__] year you know what i felt like i
couldn't make eye contact i couldn't
[__] get up in the morning i couldn't
talk to [__] people i couldn't wait i
couldn't wait for mikey to leave ari
came here one time i couldn't wait for
him to [__] leave for a year i
[__] suffered in silence but i did
the work behind the scenes and here we
are today ready to sling dick i'm going
to jiu jitsu tomorrow at 12 and that's
all that matters a shout out to my coach
sean over at jiu jitsu who's taking me
under his [__] wing and look i'm a
new [__] man [__] we got on it
we had the cyber sale last monday i put
up the freeze pipe video the [__]
freeze pipe video people went [__]
nuts i love you [__] on it
still got their sale going on freeze
pipe got that [__] sale going on
draftkings zip recruiter we got it going
on for 2022 i love you [__] i
hope you have a great monday i hope you
have a great week
watch true [__] story with kevin hart
and my man from new jack city and watch
[__] king richard i don't want to
hear about his past life or his
daughters or why he what
what's that song by bruce springsteen i
went down was i loved that song
everybody got a hungry heart
i went
buffalo jack i went out for a ride and i
never came back that's it
like a river that's going overflown
that's it baby that's my [__] story i
love you [__] with all my heart
have a great week thank you for watching
the joint and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you for listening to the joint
today uh you know it was what it was
i was a little upset about uh will
smith's movie because there's always
somebody who wants to talk about your
[__] past or what you did 23 years
ago [__] those [__] like i said
the joint is sponsored by better help
online therapy listen better help want
you to know the truth about some of the
stigmas around mental health listen i
know you're feeling a little weird
somebody is
the world just changed the last 19 20
months she's supposed to feel [__]
weird
but therapy is here to help you many
people think that therapy is for crazy
people but it's really not man i thought
the same thing too i went to a couple
group therapy things and i didn't feel
too good about it but i'll tell you
after the last year i had to do
something and somebody referred better
help to me and i met with a dana called
i met with a counselor called dana and i
got to tell you man i feel a lot better
therapy doesn't mean there's something
wrong with you it means you recognize
that we're all humans
and that we all have emotions and you
know you gotta learn to control them and
not avoid them because they're gonna pop
up and that's what happened with me i
wasn't smoking dope so all those things
i had buried were coming up and i had i
had to [__] flush him out so i
contacted betterhelp.com and dana's
there for me therapy is a tool
to utilize before things get worse and i
was bad man so don't wait until things
are unbearable like i did jump right now
everybody needs a little help let me
tell you something
uh better help is more affordable than
in-person therapy again better help is
more affordable
than in person therapy it's customized
online therapy they offer video phone
even live chat sessions if you don't
want to see no one the camera won't see
you either so it's fine
it's much more affordable and yes you
can start communicating with your
therapist in less than 48 hours that's
pretty big right there so if you contact
if you contact better help today they'll
reach out to you like by wednesday take
their little survey pay attention to
what they're doing answer honestly and
man you're going to get some great
results give it a try and see why over 2
million people have used better help
online therapy and just for the joint
listeners i'm going to do this this is
cheap as it is but you're going to get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com diaz
d-i-a-z that's betterhelp.com
diaz take control of your life and get
the help you deserve better help
the joint is also brought to you by zip
recruiter i just showed mikey rush
my emails i got 10 of them and three of
them are from zip recruiter because i
sent them a fugazi
resume i didn't know what i was doing i
didn't do it on purpose i just i haven't
filled out a resume in years and every
day they come back to me like 10 jobs
listen as the holidays approach there's
still a lot of jobs to fill you know so
if you got a job opening and you need
help filling it and right now everybody
needs help i don't know why half the
world isn't on zip recruiter because
it's for free
right now ziprecruit.com
joey is free zip recruiter uses the
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates with your job
in mind you can easily review your
recommendations and invite your top
choices to apply
it's so effective zip recruiter that
four out of five employers who post get
a quality candidate within the first day
zip recruiter is rated it's the number
one rated hiring site
in the u.s why because they're so
effective that four out of five
employers know
this is the real deal i don't care if
you got a small business or a [__]
company that's busting at the seams
right now you could try ziprecruiter for
free joey what are you talking about
ziprecruiter.com
joey j-o-e-y that's ziprecruited.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire and do not forget you don't want to
kick up 20 22 all [__] up that's why
i'm offering you on it they had their
black
friday cyber sale on monday but listen
they're offering 60 discounts on
everything kettlebells club bats
shroom tech black label protein bites
hydrotech
listen energy new mood listen i've been
working with them for 12 years i love
them i went through my alpha brain cycle
earlier this year from august to
september and that's why we're here
that's also part of what helped me out
it helps you focus it gives you laser
focus alpha brain let me tell you some
it's the only product they have that if
you don't like you get your money back
they don't even want the product back no
questions asked go to honda.com take a
look at all that great supplements and
make up your own mind and what you need
to get through for your health
right now go to on it pressing code joey
j-o-e-y
diaz whatever try something i don't give
a [__] but you try and get 10 off
delivered right to your house thank you
guys i want to thank honett i want to
thank zip recruiter i want to thank
better help on a beautiful monday i have
better help in all these the reason why
i have these i know these products will
help you guys i'm not just sitting here
[__] jumping up and down i got 20
people a day reaching out for me to help
them i like these products and that's
why give them a try whether it's better
help zipper on it you won't be let down
i love you [__] with all my
heart don't forget they got tons of
[__] uh laughing gas at the ice cream
shop if you buy laughing gas from any
other place it's not the real laughing
guy so i'm giving you guys a heads up
stay black i love you [__] and
i'll see you wednesday morning
tip top magoo
you